STEELE WITH ONE OBJECTIVE,
DESTROY DONALD TRUMP BY ANY
MEANS NECESSARY.
AND THAT’S THE ANGLE.
JOINING US NOW, FORMER
HILLARY CLINTON ADVISOR, THE
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK ROGUE
SPOOKS.
ALONG WITH "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
COLUMNIST CHEMIST RUSSELL.
I’M NOT A PROPER PERSON BUT I
HAVE A GAVEL IN CASE THINGS GET
REALLY NASTY.
>> YOU CAN POUND THE TABLE.
>> I’M NOT A MAN OF VIOLENCE.
>> I WANT TO CONGRATULATE YOU,
YOU ARE WEARING THE BRIT HUME
BOCA RATON SWEATER TONIGHT, YOU
ALREADY WIN POINTS.
TELL ME ABOUT THIS IDEA AND WE
HEARD IT FROM TREY GOWDY THAT AT
LEAST PART OF THIS DOSSIER, PART
OF THE INFORMATION IN IT CAME
FROM SID BLUMENTHAL THEN WE’LL
TALK ABOUT CODY SHEARER.
>> I SAID THIS ON YOUR SHOW LAST
WEEK, THEY COULDN’T PUBLISH THE
NEGATIVE RESEARCH THAT THEY DID
UNDER THEIR NAMES BECAUSE THEY
WERE SO DISCREDITED.
SO THEY LAUNDERED IT THROUGH
STEELE.
HE IS A FOREIGN SERVICE PERSON,
HEAD OF THE RUSSIA BUREAU OF AM
I SIX.
AM
I SIX, IT WAS PRESENTED AS HIS
WORK, IT WOULD BE A BETTER
CHANCE OF TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
I BELIEVE THAT MOST OF THE
DOSSIER WAS WRITTEN BY SHEARER
INTO BLUMENTHAL.
THEY ARE THE CLASS A DIRTY OPS,
BLACK OPS PEOPLE.
HILLARY AT ONE POINT CALLED ME
IN THE 96 CAMPAIGN AND SAID I
REALLY WANT YOU TO GET TO KNOW
SIDNEY BLUMENTHAL.
BILL FOLLOWED UP AND SAID THAT
SHE TALK TO ABOUT SYDNEY, EVERY
TIME I MET WITH HIM AFTER A WEEK
I WOULD CALL HILLARY.
HE WAS THE DIRTY TRICKS
OPERATIVE.
I ASKED BLUMENTHAL WHO WAS
ALLEGEDLY A JOURNALIST FOR THE
NEW YORKER WHO ASKED ALL THE
QUESTIONS.
>> Laura: IT DOESN’T MEAN THAT
HE IS NECESSARILY THE SOURCE OF
THE DOSSIER, THE FACT THAT HE
DID ALL THE STUFF IN THE 90s,
HOW DO WE JUMP TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT HE DID THIS.
YOU HEARD WHAT GAUDI SAID, HE
HAS A LONG HISTORY.
HE WAS SO RADIOACTIVE THAT EVEN
RAHM EMANUEL BANNED HIM FROM THE
OBAMA WHITE HOUSE BECAUSE HE
BELIEVED BLUMENTHAL WAS BEHIND
ALL OF THE NEGATIVE STUFF THAT
CAME OUT ABOUT OBAMA AND THE
2008 CAMPAIGN WHICH THEY WERE
RIGHT ABOUT.
>> LET ME SAY THAT I AGREE WITH
SOMETHING SAID.
WHICH IS THAT STEELE IS A
RENOWNED MI6 AGENT AND A FOREIGN
SERVICE AGENT.
AS TO WHY THEY FUNNELED IT AND
LAUNDERED IT THROUGH HIM THAT
YOU’VE GOT A PROBLEM.
I THINK HE JUST GAVE CREDENCE TO
THE REST OF THE DOSSIER.
TREY GOWDY DIDN’T SAY WHO IT WAS
BUT LET’S STIPULATE --
>> Laura: DEVIN NUNES DID THE
SAME THING.
>> I’VE NEVER HEARD OF CODY
SHEARER.
>> YOU HAVEN’T WORKED WITH THE
CLINTONS AS LONG AS I HAVE.
>> I ACTUALLY HAVE, I WASN’T
FIRED BY THEM.
>> Laura: THAT’S A LOW BLOW.
>> SAID IS A LOT MORE OF A
CHARACTER THAN YOU ARE
PORTRAYING.
I’M NOT DEFENDING HIM.
BUT I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS THE NOTION THAT THE
DOSSIER WAS WRITTEN BY SID
BLUMENTHAL IS CRAZY.
THAT’S NOT WHAT HAPPENED.
CHRIS STEELE WROTE THE DOSSIER.
AND DEVIN NUNES HAS SAID THAT
MUCH IN IT.
>> LET’S TALK ABOUT CHRISTOPHER
STEELE AT FOR A LITTLE BIT
BECAUSE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
MEMO TODAY IS THAT IT PROVIDES
PROOF AND INFORMATION THAT
MR. STEELE WENT TO THE FBI AND A
SUPPOSEDLY HE WAS SO WORRIED
ABOUT THE COUNTRY AND
DONALD TRUMP.
HE BROKE FBI CARDINAL RULES.
HE UNDERMINED AT THE FBI, THEY
HAD ADMONISHED HIM NOT TO SPEAK
TO ANYONE AND YET HE WENT
RUNNING OUT TO SIT DOWN WITH
GLENN SIMPSON, AN OPPOSITION
RESEARCH FIRM AND BRIEF ALL OF
THEIR BODIES IN THE PRESS IN
SEPTEMBER IN ORDER TO CREATE
NEGATIVE HEADLINES AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
HE BLEW THE OPERATION, PUT IT
OUT THERE IN PUBLIC.
THEN THEY HILLARY CLINTON
CAMPAIGN CAPITALIZED ON IT IN
THE DAYS FOLLOWING.
TELL ME HOW WE VIEW THIS MAN AS
A STAND-UP MI6 AGENT THAT CAN BE
TRUSTED.
IF HE UNDERSTOOD THE RULES OF
THE GAME, HE WILL NOT HAVE
BROKEN ALL OF THE FBI RULES.
HE STRIKES ME AS A POLITICAL
OPERATOR WHO IS ON THE RECORD AS
SAYING HE IS OPPOSED TO
DONALD TRUMP EVER BECOMING
PRESIDENT.
>> I’M NOT DEFENDING CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT HE SAID IN THE DEPOSITION
THAT HE GOT A LOT OF HIS
MATERIAL FROM AN OUTSIDE SOURCE,
UNSOLICITED.
LET’S REMEMBER THAT THIS GUY WAS
THE BUREAU CHIEF AT MI6, WHO
SAID WERE PEEING ON THE BED.
>> Laura: HE SAID CARTER PAGE
MET WITH INDIVIDUALS THAT HE
NEVER MET WITH.
>> A GUY WHO WAS SERVING A 40
YEAR SENTENCE FOR IN A GOUT
LOG -- 80% OF THAT DOSSIER IS SO
CLEARLY A LIE.
>> IF 20% IS REAL,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A BIG
PROBLEM.
>> COULD WE HEAR WHAT THE 20% IS
THAT’S TRUE?
>> BOB MUELLER IS GOING TO TELL
US.
>> Laura: IS IT STANDARD NOW
YOU CAN SPY ON AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN WITH A DOCUMENT THAT ITS
PROVIDENCE IS UNCLEAR, IT’S
VIOLATED THE NORMS OF
INTELLIGENCE BY SHARING
INFORMATION WITH THE PRESS
BEFORE IT HAS BEEN SUBMITTED TO
THE FISA COURT.
THE FBI ITSELF KNEW THE ORIGIN
OF THIS DOCUMENT WAS FUNDED BY
POLITICAL OPPOSITION, NOT JUST
AN OPPOSITION PERSON BUT THE
OPPOSITION CANDIDATE.
IF YOU CAN SPY ON AMERICANS ON
THAT BASIS I FIND IT TO BE
TERRIFYING.
>> THAT’S NOT THE BASES.
THE BASIS FOR THE WARRANT AS
WE’VE LEARNED IS THAT GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS THE COFFEE BOY.
>> AT 28-YEAR-OLD KID GOES INTO
A BAR.
HE BOASTS ABOUT HOW GREAT HE IS.
>> WON THE FISA WARRANT WAS
GRANTED, CARTER PAGE WAS
LISTENED IN ON AN EVERY 90 DAYS
THEY RENEWED IT.
>> Laura: ON THE SAME FUNNY
BASIS.
>> YOU CAN’T RENEW IT UNLESS
IT’S BASED ON WHAT THE 90 DAYS
HAVE PROVIDED.
>> Laura: THEN THEY CONCLUDE
THAT THE DOSSIER IS A
SIGNIFICANT PART IF NOT THE
INSTRUMENTAL PART OF THE
APPLICATION WITHOUT WHICH THE
APPLICATION WILL NOT HAVE BEEN
FILED.
McCABE DID SAY THAT IN THE
TESTIMONY ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> HE SAID THAT IN THE REFERRAL
WHICH QUOTES FROM THE
APPLICATION, THE FIRST TIME
WE’VE SEEN TEXTS FROM THE
APPLICATION SAID THAT THE
APPLICATIONS RELIED HEAVILY ON
TWO PIECES OF INFORMATION.
ON THE DOSSIER AND AT THE YAHOO
NEWS ARTICLE WAS INSPIRED BY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AS WELL.
THEN TO SUGGEST SOMEHOW THERE
WAS CORROBORATION.
BY THE WAY, THE REFERRAL ALSO
AND THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT,
REVEALS TO US THAT EVEN COMEY
ADMITTED IN FRONT OF THE
SENATE’S JUDICIARY THAT THEY
HAVE EVIDENCE THEY WEREN’T ABLE
TO INDEPENDENTLY VERIFY THE
DOSSIER OR THIS ARTICLE.
WHEN HE WAS ASKED WHY THEY
NONETHELESS RAN WITH IT.
HE SAID BECAUSE HE IS A RELIABLE
GUY.
>> RON JOHNSON SWUNG AND MISSED,
DEVIN NUNES SWUNG AND MISSED,
GRASSLEY HAS TAKEN THE BATON
FROM THEM.
>> HOW IS HE SWUNG AND MISSED?
>> Laura: LET’S GO TO BRETT.
>> SIDNEY BLUMENTHAL MADE UP THE
STORY THAT HE INVESTIGATED HIS
DAUGHTER’S FIANCE.
>> Laura: WERE NOT GOING TO GO
TO ROSS PEROT.
>> BECAUSE HE’S AN ANTI-SEMITE